the layer heil pen show
[Music]
sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on
solana
luna if you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to the lay
higher plans show as always it is
powered by the vc firm icon plus capital
and it is sponsored by block five so if
you want to check them out i've left a
link somewhere in the description in the
bio i'm not really sure in the comments
so go check them out so joining me today
i have a really exciting guest somebody
who
we should have done this in person which
we were just saying before the show um
but we will do eventually but today it's
gonna be really interesting um i think
we differ on a lot of different issues
so i'm really excited to delve into this
and i'm actually under strict
instructions to make this juicy so
joining me today is the founder of what
bitcoin did journalist filmmaker and
chairman of real bedford fc it is peter
mccormack what's up peter
hi elaiah how are you are you doing well
i'm good hiding i'm good i'm just
retweeting out let's get some people in
here um yeah but look juice like just
let's get into some interesting topics
because yeah there's a lot to talk about
and yeah these podcasts where you just
go
where discover bitcoin
yeah all those kind of things they're
done over and over let's just go like if
we've got limited
let's get let's just get in some
interesting topics and let's keep it
very english and very civilized
okay let's do it as i said um we do
differ on lots of different issues but
i'm sure once we delve into them we'll
find common ground
but i know you didn't want to do the
basic stuff but i do just want to start
and talk about um real bedford fc
because that is so cool so you're the
chairman of bedford football club just
explain that to me and where does
bitcoin come into this
yet yes and no there's a complicated
answer to that so we are still going
through the process of the acquisition
uh
we've established the company nakamoto
11 limited
the team we established next season will
be called rail bedford
the team we are acquiring is bedford fc
but there are some complexities involved
in the purchase
but we are being supported by bedford
football association and getting that
over the line so there's just some
things we're dealing with there
we can't talk about it all because
there's just the things that have to be
done
um and so some people are like moaning
at us on twitter etc but yeah
once once the uh acquisition is complete
we'll explain like everything that
happened and why it took a bit of time
but yeah it's very exciting um yeah it's
the
most exciting thing in my life right now
i get to
go and watch this team every week and uh
influence their future so yeah it's very
exciting i'm loving it
yeah so what does it mean though to have
bitcoin a part of it where's the bitcoin
connection how's that come into it i
know you have the gemini sponsor which
was amazing
yeah i mean to me it was all about uh
i'm from bedford and and you know anyone
listens to my podcast or following me on
twitter i'm very proud of this [ __ ]
little town i'm from um i grew up here
my friends are here i still live here um
and it's very easy to move away from
your [ __ ] little town go to a big city
london
new york and
live that life and contribute to that
economy but i've always wanted to
support the local economy of bedford um
because it's where i'm from and i want
to help it it is a
it is a deprived town um
a lot of the big companies that used to
be here years ago aren't here anymore um
there are families here who struggle um
and i always felt like i've been so up
late i've been so lucky this last few
years and what's happened with the
podcast
um that i i was like what can i do for
my town and i always felt like it was a
town that's big enough to support a
football league club uh we don't we've
never been in the football league
bedford
has never had that and i've always felt
like it's a town that can support it
so
as a plan how can you make this happen
and uh it just hit me like six months
ago i was like well hold on a second if
i just make them the bitcoin team i know
what bitcoin is alike bitcoiners
love microstrategy even though they
don't really know what what they do or
care about it and they love michael
saylor and then that they they now
absolutely love el salvador is
everyone's favorite country i was like
well if i do a bitcoin based company and
uh maybe this is something they'll get
behind the support and if if i can make
that work then i can make the economics
work and and so far it's been fairly
successful i've sold
i think close to a million pounds of
sponsorships um our merch sales in our
live we've done nearly fifty thousand
pound in merch styles with merch sales
which for a club in the tenth tier is
like it's ridiculous i mean we're we're
heading for a year one revenue of a low
league two club and so that just puts us
in this position where we can afford to
invest in the team the players
and local football and
you know if i can make this work if i
can bring league football to bedford
that's going to create jobs in bedford
that's going to bring just like just
like something cool for the town and
then away teams coming here they're
going to bring fans who are going to
spend money in the town so like this is
this is like this cool thing where i get
to
i get to do three things at once i get
to like live out a personal dream and go
on which is just a yes
every bloke's kind of one of maybe some
women too but like every bloke's kind of
dream is to own their their local
football club um i get to do that i get
to uh support my local town which i love
and i also get to promote bitcoin i just
bring all
like allowing these things to converge
at once so
so yes it's amazing i feel very blessed
and lucky that people are supporting
this
that's amazing when i saw you doing it i
was so
um i was like so happy because i love to
see people staying true to who they are
and um you know with the success kind of
giving back um no so i i love it like
i'm following your journey and i'm a fan
i think it's great um
so yeah let's go into this okay so when
we were talking about you know what we
should what we should talk about you
said to me um you know
people call you and i quote a statist
cuck i don't know what that means okay i
don't know what that means i know what
status is i don't know a carcass
honestly you definitely know what a cuck
is coming you just don't want to make
a man whose wife is sexually unfaithful
that's uh that's what they refer to
so
uh i think it's just it's used as like a
uh it's a derogatory term to imply that
you're a bit of a [ __ ] or something um
right and because i'm somebody who's
like there's in the bitcoin community
there's a lot of libertarians and uh
people who think democracy is completely
failed they want a downfall of the state
and i am somebody who believes in
democracy and and we can get into that
it's not just like
some irrational
opinion i've come to
i am somebody who believes in democracy
and rather than burn it down i'd like to
strengthen it i recognize its uh
failings but i spend a lot of time
researching it i
i don't just
look at uh democracy i look at other
forms of governance and
it's an error i'm really interested in
but but often i get called a status cuck
online which
which has
it's it's a it's a strange term to throw
at someone because it's kind of coercive
because who wants to be called a [ __ ]
and i want to be called a car can i also
be called a [ __ ] so it's kind of a
coercive term it's like well if you're
if you're a believer in democracy and if
you uh then you're a [ __ ] and therefore
you're a percy and you're not one of us
and therefore like who's gonna admit
that so what it does it actually stifles
debate about what is a really super
important subject is governance like how
do we govern ourselves
uh everyone is looking
at canada right now and seeing how
authoritarian they are becoming but
that's only within
our cohort um they
their parliamentary vote went through
overwhelmingly um to extend the
uh special powers and also if you if you
kind of slip out of you this kind of
bitcoin or crypto cohort and you go into
some of the other fees or other
discussions regarding this there's lots
of people who very much against the
truckers
uh and who very much support the
government what they're doing
so
um
for me um yeah being called to stay this
cocky it's kind of annoying um but at
the same time i'm not going to be
coerced into changing my beliefs i'm i
am someone who believes in democracy and
it comes from uh
a number of different angles and
it also comes with this thing where
people are like oh if you believe in the
government
uh then you're not a bitcoiner like or
you don't understand bitcoin and i
always think again that's kind of like a
statement um of that comes from kind of
a naive and immature place because uh
bitcoin has no political political idea
like ideology is
it's money and yes it's money outside of
the control of the state but it doesn't
it doesn't define it as a as a way to
bring down the state it is not implied
that by using bitcoin you're you're
trying to bring down the state for me
bitcoin is actually
something that i think can make
democracy stronger by becoming a a check
against power a check against the state
by uh hopefully leading to more
uh
responsible economic policy and if you
look to somebody like josh mandela who's
in ohio at the moment and you can watch
his debate between himself and morgan
harper and he's a bitcoinman but he what
he talks about is smaller government
bigger people and if you want for
smaller and bigger people you support
bitcoin if you want for big government
small people then you don't support
bitcoin so i'm kind of in that space and
i'm not just going to be sucked in and
say um oh i'm a libertarian let's burn
it all down or
um let's um get rid of the state um just
because other people are saying it
because i just don't believe it
so i think it's an important subject and
it's something that's kind of like worth
diving into
yeah let's go into it because um this is
something that i always kind of found
that i didn't understand with you and i
think a lot of people might feel similar
who identify themselves as bitcoins or
whatever so to choose bitcoin right and
to sort of put it on this pedestal is
this idea that you in my opinion are
suspicious of
authority that's why we want to
decentralize the power decentralize the
network you're suspicious of
central banks because they print more
money
do you agree
i'm not suspicious that the suspicion is
like oh i think something might be
happening i'm not suspicious at all i
think
i think government and central uh
central banks have been hugely
irresponsible with economic policy for
this
but for decades now i mean they used to
run surpluses and and deficits now
there's there's no such thing as a
surplus everything is a deficit and a
growing deficit you know we've moved
from this place of kind of
financial responsibility i'm not
suspicious i i absolutely detest what
they've done but
just because i don't like what's
happened with central banks and
government doesn't mean i want to burn
it all down it's just we've evolved to
this place and i think it's like how do
you strengthen it now
yeah i agree i also don't want to burn
it down i would i would call myself a
libertarian but i don't think we should
burn it down and i'm for democracy not
an anarchist at all but i just feel that
how do you swear that
how do you square yourself as a
libertarian
but for democracy
so i think that there's a spectrum like
i don't think everything is black and
white and so i generally speaking i'm a
libertarian that believes in small
government
and i'm suspicious of government so when
the lockdown started i was very very
suspicious
mainly because you know i saw what
happened in the 20th century and i
understand that if you give a little bit
they will take a mile
and so this is another topic i wanted to
get into with you you were pro lockdown
and i understand that for a very short
short amount of time
what happened what changed
well i just saw the evidence that didn't
work i mean at the very start the reason
i was pro lockdown is because
firstly we had these kind of weird
videos coming out of china
people collapsing on the floor and dying
but i was following the news reports in
italy italy was the first country in
europe that was you know severely
affected by covid um and uh i was
following the journalists reports going
into these
uh villages and towns that were showing
that people like a lot of people the
hospitals were overrun and people were
dying and because italy was the first
that was badly hit so it looked scary i
then did an interview for my other i
used to have the other podcast defiance
and i did an interview with my friend
who's a doctor in london that interview
is still available and he he i mean he
cried in the interview he was under so
much stress because what happened was
they had a trickle
and then they had then very quickly
within a couple of days the hospital was
overrun by people and then they had to
declare an emergency because they
couldn't deal with everyone coming into
the hospital so they're having to ship
people into other hospitals so i think
there was a natural
reaction to that to say well holy [ __ ]
this we don't know how bad this is going
to be and i fully supported the idea of
of a lockdown as as a as a method of
kind of like
easing off on the pressure on what was
happening but what happened was over
time it became evident that that that
lockdowns actually had a massively
detrimental effect and i very quickly
changed my mind and yeah
thinking that a lockdown is a good idea
doesn't make you an evil person you know
it came from a rational place and when i
was wrong i i
admitted i was wrong i was like i got
this wrong but i can't say it i would
change my view in the same situation
because in the same situation i'd be
dealing with the same information
i think at the time it it was logical
for many people to think okay a lockdown
seems like a good idea but we were told
it was a two-week lockdown
but why did you believe them why did you
believe them that's what i'm saying with
this like suspicious mentality why did
you believe it would just be two weeks
i'm just going with the information
that's put in front of me that i'm uh
speaking to a doctor who's telling me
the hospital's overrun and seeing the uh
the government investing building these
nightingale hospitals so they could deal
with overflow and they said there was a
two-week lockdown and i was like yeah
that sounds like a sensible idea
very quickly after kind of like month
two months three months it's obvious
this isn't a good idea we saw the impact
on uh family life on businesses and you
know i very quickly changed my mind but
this is one of the problems with
something like twitter if things are
taken out of context or you you say one
especially if you've got hundreds of
thousands of followers you say one wrong
thing
these little minions want to just hold
it against you for the rest of your life
like they've never said something stupid
in their life or they've never made a
mistake and and also like
like i said this this doesn't come from
a place of like evil this comes from a
place of rationality just trying to i'm
somebody here with two children as well
who are
uh are scared because they they don't
understand what's happening so yeah it
just came from a rational place i
changed my mind quickly and i admitted i
was wrong on it
yeah and i appreciate that i think that
like i wish more people would you know
be um confident and confident with
themselves enough to be presented with
new information and say actually you
know i feel a bit differently on the
topic but there's a sorry there's an
inertia to
admitting you're wrong so what a lot of
people do if they've got something wrong
they will double down i've historically
found that actually if you if you get
make a mistake and you admit you're
wrong and say you're sorry you have this
like small percentage of people who
who will like be like oh you're a
flip-flopper but generally speaking what
happens you build a trust in your
audience because your audience goes oh
well look he makes mistakes and he
admits when he's wrong okay great i can
trust him i can trust what's coming out
of his mouth is probably the truth and
you just have to accept like there's
this small little angry crowd of people
who who don't like you for that
yeah no i agree with you and i think um
i've been following you for a while and
i think that what i've noticed that
you've changed your stance on a lot of
different things
since
being in crypto bitcoin and since you
know building more of a community and
more friendships in the bitcoin
community and one that i noticed was
guns
am i right you change your stance on
guns
i have a complex id i have a complex
view on guns
so uh i was very like yeah i mean i was
very anti-gun four or five years ago
because um we don't have guns here
really i mean some some people own guns
but i'd only shot a shotgun once clay
pigeon shooting
quite happy to live in a society without
guns and i i don't really want it i you
know i'm a bit older than you so i
remember the hungerford killings where
michael ryan uh
ran around hungerford and killed some
like 13 people
uh you might not even uh you probably
don't because you're quite young you
probably don't even remember um
dunblane because i was about 15 when
that happened and that was up in
scotland where uh i can't remember his
name but this weirdo went into a school
and shot a bunch of bunch of kids i just
don't like guns and i don't like gun
crime
um and then also just seeing the massive
shootings over the years in the us i'm
i'm just not a fan of guns so i was very
much anti-guns and and now i've got to
kind of again
try and take a nuanced position as best
possible um
when i go to the us
uh i love to go shooting i've been
shooting with jameson larp i've been
shooting recently with a few beam texas
i enjoyed it and i've learned a lot
about gun safety and and such um and
i mean firstly i wouldn't be arrogant
enough to say that um i think my opinion
matters or what the rights for people
i'd have guns in the u.s and i have
definite empathies with both sides of
the argument because i've interviewed
people who are proponents of guns people
like ragnar
uh i also interviewed a lady works for a
charity called texas consent sense who
her son unfortunately killed himself
with a gun so i've seen the range of
uh arguments for it but what i would say
is like
whilst i appreciate and understand guns
in in the us i have no desire
to change
the rules in the uk and i wouldn't even
do it just to virtue signal to bitcoin
as you listen to my show i think
bringing guns into the uk would be an
absolute disaster i don't i mean look if
you really want in the gun in the uk you
can get a gun by the way you can get a
shotgun you can get a gun you just
there's just very strict restrictions on
how the cabinet they're held in how it's
locked and they come and do checks but
do i want liberal gun policies in the uk
like they have in texas that anyone can
go buy a gun no i mean
and i don't think it's you know we have
a social contract here in the uk and and
we have a democracy and if it was put
out to vote i i think you would have a
very tiny vote i mean i i imagine less
than five percent of people would want
it
so this kind of like and this goes to
this idea of trying to export cultures
around the world or just because you
know just because people in america have
their first and second amendment they
think the rest of the world should have
it but trying to export the cult uh
export the culture of america across the
world has have met many negative
externalities i think i've just come to
the point of trying to appreciate that
different countries have different
cultures i enjoy guns in the u.s i don't
really want them here
that is a very um
nuanced and gray-ariad response
i agree that it would be irresponsible
to adopt the gun culture in america in
the u.s
in the uk it just
wouldn't work
um but in terms of if you look at canada
though do you think we should do you
think we should have guns here
i don't think it would work and i think
it would be dangerous
because i just think that i support guns
like i i support guns i think i think
guns are very important i'm suspicious
of the government um the last two years
has shown me um you know
we need to protect ourselves and
particularly with what's going on in
canada um but i think it would be like
the pros would outweigh the cons in some
way i think if we had you know guns
suddenly imported into the uk
it would be disastrous so you mean the
you mean the cons would outweigh the pro
the the cons with outweigh the pro thank
you yeah thanks that could be taking out
contacts and i i just don't think i know
that you in america in 1776 because they
had guns they were able to take on our
tyrannical british government and throw
a tea into the sea and yada yada um i
just don't see a scenario in the uk
whereby like
we have that uprising which requires us
to have guns to take on the target
government and yes it could happen but
it's i think i'm thinking about
probabilities i think the probability of
a scenario where we as a nation needs to
rise up i just think it's unlikely and
and i think the net effect on guns in
the uk would be negative we already have
a knife issue and uh i don't think
throwing guns into that mix is uh
particularly useful i was uh i was
having um
i was having uh lunch with an old school
friend the other day in the gym and uh
he works for the police he works from
the net and he works on organized crime
he said there's such an issue with
getting guns in this country it's so
hard to get a gun guns are reused so
what happens is a gun will be used in
multiple crimes so one person will have
it and then it goes to another and they
loan it they loan it out around the
country
to be able to do these crimes there was
a scarcity of guns so if there were more
guns there wouldn't be that scarcity and
then there would likely be more crime
associated with it and yes look i don't
have a gun to defend myself in my house
but the uk is relatively safe and when
people bring up the knife crime it's it
really is that's mainly gang on gang
crime that is a a
an issue of deprived estates where
there's no opportunity a lack of
parenting a lack of father figure and
people are joining gangs and and part of
being in the gangs haven't having a
knife so i just don't i just don't see
any positive uh outcome for the uk
having a a gun culture like the us
my only issue with that is i know you
said we're relatively safe here
but we could have been canada like we
could have been canada and i think what
concerns me with canada it's not it's
not similar to america because the
restrictions are different you just you
can't even leave your country you're
literally a prisoner to your country
unless you've not had a certain medicine
i want to like keep um buzzwords off
this um you know you're you're literally
a prisoner in your own country you can't
even get a domestic flight if you
haven't had medicine but it's not a
medicine
it is what it is but i don't want to say
certain words because youtube will just
i don't know demonetize shadow and stuff
like that but you know what i'm
referring to yeah of course but
they have guns in canada so why why
aren't the truckers bringing out their
guns
i mean it's not a scenario rules
uh i don't think so exactly i don't
think it's the exact same rules but but
you can have guns in canada
but what what do you think would happen
like if they had i mean
look at new york you've got uh you've
got quite you've got mandates within new
york i was meant to be there this week i
couldn't go because my daughter's not
vaccinated so that that can happen i
mean look what what do people suddenly
think in these scenarios everyone's
going to suddenly bring out their guns
and you've got to remember that
whilst trudeau in our cohort is not
particularly popular there are other
people who do support him so what
they're going to descend into civil i
don't think this is a scenario where
they descend into civil war
and i don't think this is so i think
we're
we're far from that uh and you know
well i mean like i'm a massive critic
critic of uh uh
justin trudeau i think he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but at the same time like they're
a democracy and he's democratically
elected
and uh and my my biggest criticism is
they're trying to uh clamp down on
dissent and use tools such as uh uh
uh like blocking your finances to stop
descend i think that's bad but that may
be something they go through the
democratic process and and a
conservative party comes in and repeals
that i don't know how it works out but
at the moment i'm i'm not seeing a
scenario where i'm like oh we suddenly
need a us-based gun policies in the uk
yeah and i understand that i think um
the last two years has just pushed me
and a lot of other people and i think
even you to some extent more towards a
certain you know smaller government
ideology um and i would never i would
never say it would never come to the uk
because i think we were so close to
being um to being canada but in terms of
you know without knife
but really
no i take issue with that how do you
think we were so close to becoming
canada
because there was there was a moment we
had vaccine passports for starters right
we had those all be it was for three
weeks i truly believe if yeah we did for
three weeks we had vaccine passports
and major for like for like um for like
clubs for major things like um
clubs big big events concerts that was
the idea that's what was implemented
yeah
for a very short period of
time for three weeks
during a pandemic when you know people
are getting sick and dying that it was a
tool of the government to try and open
up the economy by what but at the same
time but but at the same time inventory
and it's not okay
well no look look i think i think you
can look into the nuance of this look i
don't support mandates and passports but
i understand what the government was in
a tricky position because uh they're
trying to
the role of the government is to support
the electorate and the electorate is
what votes and puts the government in
power
and the electorate is a wide range of
views from those who are uh uh who
believe in like ultimate freedom and and
those who want safety from the
government and they're in a very tricky
position and the nhs was completely
overrun at one point now there were
people dying they're vulnerable people
dying people with co-morbidities and
i think whilst i disagree with the
lockdown the government's in a very
tricky position in that they're trying
to open up the economy but trying to
protect the national health service at
the same time so i think what it was
naturally doing was trying different
tactics and one of the tactics is saying
look if you're going to go to wembley
stadium uh and going to go and watch
england ideally you don't have covert
because it's a it's a it's a
event with a lot of people and it could
lead to a big spread and that spread
could lead to a lot of people going to
hospital
and a lot of sickness and illness so i
don't support passports we understand
why they did it but i think it's a
massive stretch to say that we're close
to becoming canada we could have been
because they think the reason why all of
this has been reversed is for several
reasons first reason is because boris
johnson broke our lockdown rules right
or his own lockdown rules how can you
implement further things if you didn't
even take the damn thing seriously in
the first place if your leaders aren't
afraid of the virus like why should
anyone else be so that's the first thing
how can you get how can you continue
second thing is i think that we had a
lot of um
people
speaking out against it online
um and i and you know really holding the
government to account because we had
those kind of leaders
um and i think they we i for me
personally like i think we owe them a
huge like thank you for you know every
single day fighting speaking um and
standing up for it
if we didn't have that i think we would
have continued i mean we didn't even
have any opposition from the labour
party i mean kierstarma was totally in
favor of more restrictions back in
december but this is how democracy works
democracy works in that you have the
push and pulling within government and
you have the push and pull of the people
and you have the you have the right to
demonstrate you have the right to
protest now we had the right to protest
in the uk
and there were protests and people were
heard we were i would say during this
entire process we've been a very well
functioning democracy which is that
sometimes done things that like people
disagree with but i think this is why
sometimes it's important to step out of
your cohort because within your cohort
it's very easy to think like everything
is uh authoritarian everyone is becoming
a nazi but if you actually step out of
that cohort and go and look into
different groups like a large percentage
of the population very much supported
what the government did this is why i
spent so much time talking to doctors
and nurses visiting hospitals and
speaking to people on the front lines
because
they were the people who say to you look
we're in a difficult situation here at
times yeah these hospitals were overrun
they were dealing with lots of people
dying now that doesn't mean lay i don't
criticize the government and the
complete [ __ ] hypocrites i do i
absolutely [ __ ] criticize them but at
the same time i i don't i think it's a
long stretch to say we're close to
becoming canada i actually think as a
democracy we function really well you
know if you actually look in europe
we probably outside of like sweden and
belarus we're like one of the first
countries to completely open back up and
start pulling back the restrictions
which surprises me
it surprises me but that's where i'd
like that's where i challenged you we
were close to becoming canada i think
we're a long way from becoming canada i
think we actually functioned as a
democracy in this process now listen not
again again refer back to our cohort a
lot of people in it will not agree with
it because they just hate any form of
government so any kind of like
any kind of like rope i give them any
kind of like leeway i give them like
well [ __ ] you government's terrible but
i am somebody who supports democracy and
i think we function as a democracy
fairly well we saw the flaws in
government and what we're seeing is you
know people were removed from government
uh
hancock the absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
was a complete hypocrite and he's you
know he lost his uh place in the cabinet
uh boris johnson's massively under
threat almost certainly the
conservatives will not be voted in in
the next election because because of
their handling this and their parties
and that's how democracy works my my
biggest problem with democracy is
is that we have this great pull between
the left and the right and especially in
the uk being a
not being a two-party system we have
that kind of like ability that if you're
if you're if you're pissed off with a
conservative pistol for labor well
there's other parties you can vote for
you can influence they don't have that
in the u.s but my biggest problem is
whether you have this poll left or right
because you know yeah they had that
pendulum swinging from you know from
more conservative policies to more
liberal policies government still gets
bigger and this is where i wish
libertarians would engage in politics
more because
yeah i fundamentally agree with
libertarians i just think a lot of the
ideas just don't work out in reality but
if libertarians if there were like
libertarian parties with a larger uh uh
control of the vote especially in a
representative democracy
as well as having that left and right
you would hopefully have that pull
between big and small government we
don't have that thing that is trying to
create smaller government because
government always gets bigger it's what
eric voorhees told me years ago he said
i just wish government would get smaller
i think if we had more libertarians in
government and more like a stronger
libertarian party not only we would have
that push left and right which balances
the needs of different people in society
we would also have that push and pull on
the size of government
that's a really good point actually
didn't occur to me um because we often
think you know by voting conservative
you're voting for a smaller government
but you're not
can i um i just want to respond to
somebody i'm just seeing one of the
comments there is no democracy it's only
two parties in the uk labor or
conservative anything else is a wasted
vote this guy has no clue actually that
guy has no clue because what he doesn't
understand is that um for example with
the liberal democrats they actually had
a role in government because you have to
have a like i don't know what the
percentage of the vote is um though so
they ended up uh becoming part of
government because that's 51 you have to
have 15 if you can't then is it 51 i
thought it was more than that but they
ended but they ended up being able to
bring liberal democrat policies into
government because they needed that
coalition so unfortunately that guy
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about
yeah so yeah you do need you need 51
which is what happened in 2010 we um we
had the hung parliament and so
they were supposed to do they weren't
supposed i think it was the
conservatives i can't remember so long
ago well it was the conservatives yeah
but what if
the problem with it was is they had a
weak person in charge of liberal
democrats who ended up giving up all of
that miliband
no no ed miliband's labour um
oh
i can see his face but i remember his
name that's how irrelevant and weak he
is i'm too old i'm terrible with names
but they ended up kind of relenting on
anything which the liberal democrats
stood for just to get that part in
government which was a real shame but to
say it's just a two-party system is is
um just wrong
yeah so yeah it's it's uh i get why
people say it's a two-party system but
obviously they they did have an effect
especially when it came to rising um
increasing student um
student loans or just the the cost of
the cost of university that was it
because they said the lib dem said they
wouldn't increase it but then they had
to increase it because of the because of
the coalition so yeah it's true there
you go um i want to talk a little bit
about canada and what's going on with
bitcoin um it was so fascinating i think
my favorite day in bitcoin has to be
the nunchuck response for the
non-custodial wallet
that was just unbelievable um so
empowering so talk to me about you know
your thoughts on where bitcoin comes
into all of this and how the government
are going after crypto right now
yeah i mean look super interesting i
think uh some of these people within uh
the canadian government got a lesson in
what uh censorship resistance is and
self-sovereignty is uh so that was great
uh i think what happened with gofundme
and sengo whatever it's called uh i
think was a [ __ ] disgrace i mean this
was legitimate funding of a
uh of a demonstration now look we can
get into specifics because some people
say it was an occupation and uh preston
berm put out a very good tweet threat
that explained that look if if if you
wanted to stop the uh blockade that
could be done with under the laws that
currently existed and i think there are
some good arguments to say that um you
know for the people of ottawa because i
got a lot of emails from them that parts
of the blockade were actually damaging
their business somebody wrote to me and
said they couldn't get their kids to
school another person wrote to me said
their mother's operation had been put
back because she couldn't get a hospital
they are genuine issues whereby look i
support protests and sometimes you need
civil disobedience but also sometimes
you say well hold on a second if this
impacts other people's lives too
negatively we need a bit of a compromise
in there
but to actually um to actually take away
the funding of these people to be able
to afford to protest it's a disgrace uh
but this is where bitcoin comes in we
had this with um belarus where the
lukachenko is obviously a dictator
currently supporting
um
uh putin's latest adventures um he uh he
stole you know he he's a dictator of
belarus and and the bela peru's
belarusians try to uprise and one of the
ways they did that is they wanted to
bring the state down by having state
workers
um
uh strike but obviously these people
need to be able to pay their bills and
feed their family so we were able as
bitcoiners to send bitcoin to these
people in belarus and support them it's
exactly the same scenario it's exactly
the same scenario these are people who
want to be able to protest they want to
be able to raise their issues of being
mandated to have vaccines which i fully
support them on they should not be
mandated to have vaccines
and
yeah i think it was great i mean
you know the the canadian government
essentially banned these uh fundraising
platforms uh and i think it was under
terrorism laws which was ridiculous but
uh and so us was bitcoin i said great
hong kong coddle let's uh donate them
bitcoin i sent some bitcoin i know a lot
of other people and we raised a lot of
bitcoin for them and it it was amazing
to to to show them that that this is the
power of censorship resistance but there
is a flip side to this that we have to
be conscious of
you know not only are we teaching them
about censorship resistance and
self-custody we're also then advertising
this is a threat to them so do not we
should not be surprised if this leads to
maybe other forms of
regulation or attempts to get control
over this that is something we have to
be aware of
the the the benefits of censorship
resistance are also a threat to the
power so that is something we need to be
conscious of now i think we're more
protected in america at the moment
because we have a political opposition
that really heavily support bitcoin uh
there is there is also some in in canada
but it's not as widespread
ah nick clay
nick yeah i saw that as well um
i think just one thing i want to say
just about the about the truckers um and
the inconvenience that it co that it
caused my only issue with the argument
about you know people wanting to get
their kids to school and of course it's
awful you know if people can't go to
operations and things like that
the problem with that is just of course
it was an inconvenience but what about
what the government did to other people
it's an inconvenience you know so how to
how do you protest like how do you have
civil disobedience how do you do that
because you need to do that right
because your livelihood is literally
being confiscated from you
so
the only way to do that well protesting
is protesting is a spectrum
um
but for it to be effective right it has
to be on that far spectrum otherwise
nobody's gonna listen well look what
happened during the iraq war again i
don't know how old you were at that time
but they were the biggest protests in uk
in history over a million people
marching on the street everybody knew
this was going to be a criminal war it
was based on lies it was
so unpopular to the point i think we had
two politicians stepped down claire
short and another person i come for his
name
um that's a problem we get an old lady
forget people's names um
but uh you know they were they were
largely ineffective the largest protest
in uk history and we could not stop our
government entering into an illegal war
that led to the death of one a half
million people and destabilized the
entire middle east so sometimes you have
to have civil disobedience now
[Music]
the the history of
of the
humanity is littered with examples where
civil civil disobedience has been
required to change over policies
uh or policies of oppression so yes but
like i say there has to be
that
this is like a complicated area um where
i think it's important to see both and
especially if you're like
hosting a podcast or you're a journalist
i think i think it's really important to
try and seek out both sides of this
argument which is you know after i did
the interview with the uh greg farson
the guy supporting the campaign the the
canadian trackers i also then put out a
tweet saying look i want to hear from
the other side because i want to
understand who it's affected and why so
i just i just think that's more about
responsible reporting i support protests
i support civil disobedience where it's
required but i also understand that that
perhaps there's sometimes need to be
compromised it's like if this is you
know if somebody can't get to an
operation how do we fix it how do we
resolve that situation
yeah no i understand um so
i think that the
the establishment the canadian
government and so on didn't realize the
extent
of how censorship resistant bitcoin is
right like that was just obvious from
the email
so
what happens at this point because the
government is angry um
i'm always very much on the side of
bitcoin can't be banned there's always
going to you know the net like even
whether there's just two miners on the
network in el salvador the network is
still going bitcoin still exists it
can't be banned
um but what does it look like for
um innovation and our community and also
just the price as well um
if more of the establishment and world
leaders wake up to just how censorship
resistant is
well bitcoin can be banned it just can't
be stopped
i think i think that's the point you're
trying to make yeah okay
yeah you can ban it i mean bitcoin is
banned in china it hasn't stopped
everyone usually stops it correct yeah
um
but
i think there's two things government
governments can do they can ban it i
mean it has been banned in china it's
banned in bolivia i think it's banned in
pakistan um but they can they can
regulate it
to the point of being completely useless
um so
we've seen various kind of like
recommendations for
uh kyc extensions and as such within the
us that would essentially bring bitcoin
into just being a commodity where the
censorship resistance side is less
prominent it becomes more about the 21
million which is you know a bit of a bit
of a shame
um but uh
outright ban it i don't think something
that would happen in america but you
know people can regulate exchanges they
can regulate money transmitters they
could just make it very very difficult
this is why we need uh education and we
need
strong people within politics which
support bitcoin which is yeah some
people say i'll ignore politics and all
politicians actually no i think there's
been some great work done in america
working with politicians especially in
texas governor abbott i went to a
session with him ted cruz is a supporter
of bitcoin i think um uh josh mandel
senator allam is like we've got this
growing list of people who understand
bitcoin and i think once people are
educated around it once and if you pick
the right politicians politicians who
gen genuinely care about the electorate
and genuinely care about the people
which do exist
if you can find those people and educate
them about the benefits of bitcoin um
then you can avoid that kind of
situation what you've got to do is
you've got to also work on the morons
people like senator warren who continue
to disseminate misinformation she needs
to be educated on why uh bitcoin would
be good for um progressives
okay just on that point
does senator warren like she put bitcoin
and doj in the same sentence like i like
doge right i think it's really funny and
but that's it that's the extent of my
interest in doge um you know it's
obviously not bitcoin but she put
bitcoin and dojo in the same sentence
the other day didn't she say that um
elon musk didn't pay any tax so is she
just is she dumb or is this done on
purpose
i mean
how do i know how do i know what she's
up to i i i used to have faith in her i
saw her senate testimony well i mean
look when mnuchin was recommended uh
under trump i saw her send a senate
questioning of him i can't remember what
they call i'm not an american but the
the
they have to go through a process where
they're
proposed and questioned and i saw her
really go after him i i saw her uh
senate testimony here referring to
uh the removal of or the muting of
glass-steagall
um which was a a a policy which
essentially a policy change which
essentially led to the 2008 financial
crisis i saw her complaining that
goldman sachs is essentially
uh essentially has a office within
uh
the the white house like she seemed to
be going after
financial corruption and the uh the
bankers
and i was like okay this is somebody who
would understand bitcoin but actually
really she's just a mouthpiece just
she's just a mouthpiece and now she's
going against bitcoin and so this isn't
somebody cares about the people this is
somebody who just cares about uh
politicking i've got no idea who's
speaking in her ear i expect she's not
gone down the rabbit hole i don't think
she's read the bitcoin standard i don't
think she's listened to what bitcoin did
i don't think she's jumped on crypto
twitter i think she's got advisors all
these politicians they have advisors who
work with them on policy and somebody's
in her ear saying this bitcoin is bad
it's about the environment let's attack
it perhaps they're seeing that there's
republicans who are supporting bitcoin
they think they should go against it
because they want to make everything a
political football i've got no idea but
she's a liar and she's spreading
misinformation actually she's spreading
disinformation
also every time she tweets about
inflation you're like are you [ __ ]
are you are you serious like are you
lying on purpose
um so yeah i just have no faith in that
woman um
yeah no i agree with you you mentioned
you know people who are looking out for
the electorate people who actually care
and i do agree with you i always say you
know um
when a
political candidate comes out and is
supposedly pro bitcoin please have a
look at their previous voting history so
we can see whether they're using this as
a ploy to get more votes because i think
that's what that's what we're going to
start to see um so in the uk you know we
mentioned we spoke about matt hancock
earlier um so for those that don't know
matt hancock was the health secretary
during lockdown he was responsible for
all of it he was then cheating on his
wife and banging his assistant i think
during lockdown where they told us we're
not allowed to kiss anyone or have sex
with anybody outside of your household
that's what they said and you know
clearly he did quite the opposite but um
oh somebody is calling me from america
let me just decline this how weird it's
coming up on my computer um
so yeah that's what they said and i
think that so he then disappeared
but the first time i saw him again he
was talking about making the uk
this crypto friendly place now i'm like
and then i saw a lot of people
celebrating this and i don't believe it
for a second i'm just like you know
you're using this as another way to get
back into the public light you know be
liked again and so on and so on and try
to be more um
seem fresh or whatever it is so do you
believe this guy do you think you know
he's got any good intentions of making
crypto and making the uk crypto friendly
does it matter
well it does because he i believe was
also talking about cbdc's which we can
get into
exactly
obviously what we all do and and uh
magee's uh interviewed rogan this
weekend
like is really highlights the issues
with that but um
i think it doesn't matter i think it's
part of the whole game theory and
everything's good if you speak to harry
selleck he's got this like line where he
says everything's good for bitcoin um
if you if you if you look now someone
like 30 of americans own crypto or
bitcoin if you get to the point where 50
people 50 of people own bitcoin
you have an anti-bitcoin policy you you
have a policy which attacks the wealth
of the electorate
so i don't i think we get to a point
where you can't have that policy and i
hope we get into the uk yeah do i do i
do i believe and trust government as a
whole no are there individuals who i
believe are good or have good in them
yeah uh i believe people get corrupted
by the system or worn down but i mean
eureka rose i interviewed her i mean
she's fantastic she clearly wants to be
a politician because she wants to do
good if she if she does become a
politician if she does get a seat in the
congress
maybe in 20 years she's just like any
other politician but it doesn't matter
really because
if we want to grow bitcoin if we believe
this that is the ultimate good then if
these people support bitcoin fine i'll
help them i'll go see matt hancock i'll
advise him i'll tell him what he should
do with his uh bitcoin policy i've got
absolutely no issue with that whether
it's genuine or not i don't care i just
want them to support bitcoin because i
believe in bitcoin i think it's good
and i also want to talk about el
salvador because el salvador has
received so much hostility um
from the bank of england which is really
laughable from the us from the imf um
why do you think they've received so
much hostility
i mean
look
i think the early days of the buccalee
uh presidency
uh their actions he took which were
uh
which pointed towards author
authoritarian in nature can you give me
some examples well so it's i mean
they're they're a single term presidency
the constitution says so and they've
changed that policy now he'll he'll be
running for another uh
another term now listen when i
interviewed him i said to him i get it i
don't think one term is long enough to
do this but that is that is a single
person changing the the policy of a
country without um
without going to consultation
similar to the bitcoin law as much as i
support the bitcoin law it was rushed
through parliament now this is somebody
who's who's whether he's a dictator or
uh
or whatever he is somebody who's making
quick and fast decisions without really
going through consultation
that said it seems to be working
you know
you know i i think luckily we have
something like alex gladstein who's like
the conscious conscience of bitcoiners
you know he is here's the conscience
he's the guy keeping an eye on things
he's the guy who's like observing and
saying look like we need to be careful
here
um
i think
the problem that people have with el
salvador or buchelli specifically is he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about international
institutions
he just doesn't care he doesn't care
about the imf he doesn't care about the
world bank you know these people haven't
really cared for el salvador before he
recognizes that so he's doing completely
different policies and these are
policies that scare people these are
policies and i don't think it's just
about power i think it's like these
people don't actually understand bitcoin
and so they see what he's doing they
think it maybe it's irresponsible but it
doesn't matter he's doing it anyway
so
i don't know man i can't give you a
solid answer
how does this play out though because
we're yet to see right now it's an
experiment right we refer to it as like
the el salvador bitcoin experiment um
and i'm just trying to figure out how
this plays out because it kind of plays
into everything that we've been talking
about right now i think we're really at
this push and pull between um
the state and the people
and we've seen that over the last two
years it's clearly increasing canada and
all this stuff
are people going to be moving there i
mean we saw today like tourism is up 30
since the bitcoin law i don't know if
that's because of covid and things like
that
i'm just trying to figure out you know
how far they can go with this
will other latin american countries
follow
you know where's this going
listen
we're meant to not trust verify uh so
what i would say is take everything with
a pinch of salt uh i saw the double
digit gdp growth i've got no idea
you know my first question is like well
was there a gdp drop because of covid
and therefore is that the bounce back
because i know we had massive we had a
massive gdp increase in the uk but we
had that was a bounce back after covid
you know so like i do have questions
yeah it's similar what was tourism like
during covert it obviously dropped so so
i think i think
like when i saw those numbers and people
go oh my god look at this the greatest
um uh gdp growth in
the el salvador history has never been
double digits i was like well hold on a
second like just give me the data and
also at the same time like he's a
politician so one of his jobs is
marketing now i've got no idea i you
know we're meant to not trust verify so
uh i don't know the data it is a huge
experiment
who knows how this will play out but
what i would say
is i have 95 of my wealth in bitcoin for
a reason because i believe in it okay
so do i think bitcoin policy will be
good for el salvador in the long run yes
he's taken a massive brave gamble being
the first being the first is risky being
the second's left being number two three
fours less risky you don't want to be
country 150
i agree with you i think you i think the
usa is going to be country 150 i've no
way i mean i think they already probably
own a lot of bitcoin they've got bitcoin
they've confiscated they've got bitcoin
they'll probably keep i'm i i
i absolutely don't think they'll be the
final i think europe is going to be like
one of the la like the countries of
europe are going to be one of the last
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
how it plays out so we said we chat for
about an hour and we have like
10-15 minutes left and there is
something that i feel like we should get
into
um
so the other day we had a bit of a tiff
and then we said in private we don't
argue um
you made it a tiff i didn't make it a
tif you asked me how old i was
you retweeted it
it was funny because i was just having
fun no i'm just having fun
so
and i thank you the i sent you the
compromise i said let's not argue
you did and i appreciated that um so we
kind of
agree or disagree a little bit on
feminism
and um you know we wanted to get into
this and i it's not suitable you know
your podcast is very bitcoin only i'll
talk about anything i hate feminism
and you know you were sort of asking me
you know what do i do if i have you know
daughters and i want to tell them that
they can do anything
so
what is feminism
feminism
i think initially at the start feminism
i would i would believe in right in
terms of equality you know women should
have the
right to vote
and looking at like the actual
legalities in this world and sort of
saying you know do we have equal laws
like are we treated equally and for me
that's sort of where it starts and ends
right now feminism is is
i think more detrimental to women
unfortunately um i think it's gone too
far
well what part
what part has gone too far
the biggest issue and i'll tell you this
is some as a woman in her 20s who's
who's had a change of heart about a lot
of different things
feminism lies to you
okay feminism tells you
yeah feminism tells you
be a boss [ __ ]
right when you're 18 and 19 yeah sure be
a boss [ __ ]
as you get older there is no
there's no woman i'd show me a woman
who's
40 the ceo of a company super successful
no children tell me she's happy because
she's not
that's basically what the path that
feminism likes to take you down
so feminism is about telling women to
to go and be a boss [ __ ] and then they
might miss out on having a child because
i think feminism is like the scope of
feminism is way wider than that and i
think about feminism from the point of
being a single father with a daughter
who asks me questions
yeah she comes home from school she said
oh the boys got to do this why don't we
get to do it
what did they get to do
like it might be the boys play football
we don't get to play football we play
netball i'm like do you want to play
football she's like i don't know but
like
maybe
or the boys are a bit you know tend to
take over and dominate things like
yeah she just comes back with questions
and i always have to empower and say you
can do everything that a boy does or you
can do everything you know so like i i'm
trying to as a father and power to think
she is equal and this it takes me back
to this kind of world of libertarianism
one of the oh let's go to and caps one
of the reasons i have issues with
anarcho-capitalism is that
negative liberty really
uh is something i've been reading about
which is something this kind of guy
isaiah berlin wrote about but the issue
with negative liberties
empowers the strong
and um it disempowers the weak
and one of the great things i saw this
great interview with jordan peterson
where this guy talks about like the
civil rights moves civil well no he was
actually a guy making that was
challenging uh
jordan peterson with regards to uh
should should a cake shop be able to uh
refuse to make a
cake for a gay couple and he's yeah and
he said no and
and uh and then he brought him up on the
idea of the civil rights movement and
and jordan peterson you know did 180
said actually i had that issue wrong and
this is one of the things that like i
love about centralization and statism is
that that we have had these progressions
in society that have made a more equal
society that we've
we've uh we have had the civil rights
movement we have uh uh created more
equal opportunity for women in the
workplace and so me as a father like
a lot of that has come from women
themselves as well of course it has
so
yes everything is everything always has
a spectrum i'm sure of feminism there's
a bunch of absolute freaks out there who
just like
just promote really weird [ __ ] but at
the same time like
my if my daughter wants to have a career
and she wants to go out and be
successful i'm absolutely gonna support
her i'm not gonna turn around and say no
darling you need to be prepared at 24 to
start thinking about marriage and babies
because you might miss out on that later
in life i can't tell my daughter that
there's no way i can tell her that and
you're like
that might lead to her getting into her
40s and not having a child and you know
being sad about that but there's also
for every woman you say who's sad about
that there are also women who are sad
they missed out on building a career and
only raise children there's always that
thing where the grass is always greener
it's about it's about being honest it's
about having an honest conversation so i
would say i'm somewhat successful for my
age and what i do
and
i would put much of that success down to
my brother so my brother has always
empowered me right i think and this is
the thing with men and women with
feminism actually i think feminism sort
of
disregards the value of men i think
there's so much that that i can learn
from a man
to be successful in life in many
different ways not just work like i i
value men so much like i look up to men
i think men are amazing not all men
most men i think i think are pretty
great right so i would attribute a lot
of my success to my brother because he's
hugely empowered me and said to me
you can do anything your gender has
nothing to do with it but what i think
is important is to have an honest
conversation with your daughters and say
you know
have that career because i think
actually women should be financially
independent that's really important
every individual should be financially
independent so you're not um you know
relying on either the government or your
partner but have an honest conversation
and just say you know like you will turn
an age
and you don't have as much time as a man
and these things are
a matter of fact
and it's about not
not
not not addressing that because that's
what we tend to see
like i tell you i i said to this what i
think that i think there's a way bigger
problem with
dating apps than feminism for women i do
i fundament i've got a theory on this
and uh
so when i was like when i was uh your
age lei if you wanted to get a
girlfriend
you you'd have to talk to somebody in
real life human form you'd be in a bar
or
you'd be in a club and if you saw a girl
you're like god she's hot like
and i need to go and talk to her and it
was a terrifying experience
and
it made you a man and it no if you got
no no like everyone every guy is a [ __ ]
when it comes to this your partner
you've always got this like one friend
of us but like you would go and do it
right and occasionally you get rejected
and it's like it's heartbreaking it's
killer but like every now and again a
girl would be like yeah hey talk to you
back and then maybe like you would ask
her out and she'll say yes just like
holy [ __ ] i've got a date and then maybe
like after the date she would want to
see you again
and like if you were like super lucky
she would actually want to have sex sex
with you and it was like it was like
this experience that you would go
through
and
and maybe you'd be like wow this person
is amazing and you would stick with it
and it was a real challenge
for guys and women controlled it and the
problem you've got now with dating apps
it's like guys don't really have to
[ __ ] work anymore that
they've they've swapped out going up and
talking to somebody and having a pair of
balls to do that with a swipe ah she
says no great go to the next one all
right i've got 50 new matches today hey
do you want to go out join the [ __ ] like
they've just made it so easy for guys
and it's flipped the script when i speak
to my my friends who are girls they're
like it's an absolute nightmare no guy
wants to commit now
we've created this kind of like culture
of [ __ ] boys yeah there's this culture
of [ __ ] boys which is absolutely
terrible and it's flipped the script and
i think that's a bigger problem for
women in that all these girls i know in
their 30s it's not that they can't have
a baby they can't find someone to have a
baby because no guy wants to commit
it's such an interesting topic um it's
also there's so much to this that i just
shouldn't say on a podcast um
someone just as you're
speaking i'm just thinking no i mean
what were these women doing in their 30s
you know i don't know how they behave
you know you
if you want to if you want to attract
somebody of high value to have a baby
with you have to be high value yourself
and you have to compromise and you have
to do certain things so i don't know
these women in their 30s they might be
saying you know that everyone's a [ __ ]
boy but what were you how are you
behaving when you were 23 24 25
i don't know how they were behaving so
there's another there's another
you know part to that i think there are
really good men out there
i think there are really good women out
there um but if you want to attract high
value then you have to be high value and
that does mean compromising you know as
a man that might mean working incredibly
hard that might mean you know physically
looking gorgeous you know getting your
body in shape it might mean working
incredibly hard to make a lot of money
as a woman it might be sacrificing
certain things you know having to do
certain things for your husband whether
that's like
you know cooking cleaning i don't know
whatever it is but you know these these
sort of things
require compromise so i don't know what
they were doing i know that a lot of
women in their 20s unfortunately um
behave really badly so i'm not surprised
when a lot of women are just women
men and women behave badly it's like a
human nature and
on the whole i suspect it's men who tend
to behave more badly because we're
[ __ ] idiots and we don't mean that
kind of behave badly i don't mean that
kind of behavior what do you mean
i mean like oh man we could we gotta
i've gotta run you gotta run we we could
talk about this for ages are you gonna
run
i i i have a networking event tonight at
seven in an hour i've gotta okay let me
just say
what i mean by this what i mean by this
is
men don't like women that have been with
the entire community right
you just don't men just don't like that
you're avoiding this
well listen firstly there's no way a guy
has to find that out
that's secret information and and i
don't know many women like that and look
if a girl wants to go and be [ __ ] but
that's up to her i mean look of course
it's up to her but i'm just saying like
this is going to be detrimental in terms
of finding the kind of person that you
want to find and so you get to 30 and
you're wondering why you're still single
why why did why does it mean that's like
what you know who knows what's happened
maybe they've gone to university then
they've got a job now they get into
their like late 20s they want to settle
down and they just find it difficult i
think i think there's a myriad of
reasons i think it's difficult to binary
place on one thing i think also just
like the world has changed like
relationships have become like uber like
oh i want a relationship tonight i don't
want one tomorrow
yeah instant gratification i think a lot
of that's happening um
um i think that i think there's like a
whole bunch of reasons uh i know you
want to go all right
no no but like no no you need to go and
we can do this again we could do this a
hundred times look i'm i'm massively out
of my depth here i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm doing i've got a 12 year old a
12 year old girl who like comes to me
and asks me stuff and there is no way i
can turn around her and say
darling listen you need to be preparing
for when you're about 24 25 think about
having a baby because it's gonna be
harder in your 30s and so you need to
find yourself a man and you know who can
look after you i just i can't do that i
can't have that conversation maybe her
mom can maybe that can come from her mum
but i'm not gonna like perpetuate this
belief in her her eyes that like it's a
man's world because it still exists
but it's not a man's word i'm not saying
it's a man's world because
it's such a such a kind of worms it's
not a it's not a man's world
um i have right now i would actually
argue that it's it's both it's both but
you know
there's a lot of advantage to being a
woman in this world right now um
but as a 12 year old girl
i don't think there's many guar like
boys coming home from school and saying
to their their dad go ahead oh the girls
get to do this i wish we did i don't i
don't think that happens as much but it
definitely happens with a 12 year old
girl so there still is that thing and
you know and i i just i don't have it in
my heart to turn around her and say
sorry darling but like you need to be
like like say maybe it's this
conversation for our mum to have and
that that's fair
but i don't i don't have that in me i
just i can't do that
no i respect that but what i will what i
will say you've got this guy matthew
that matthew mccauley following the
conversation like he's just let me see
he just
is correct
wait where is it oh it's gone
women's fertility is fine
talk you know what peter we need to do
an impersonal podcast okay no i'm just
going to reply to him like of course i
can explain biological reality mate i
can explain biological reality but at
the same time i'm balancing the hopes
and dreams of a young girl i'm not going
to try and crush it by telling her at 12
years old she needs to think about
having a baby you [ __ ] idiot
i'm just reading your comments
what i'll say is this is this is my this
is like where my feminism starts and
ends it's that every individual
including women should never rely on
somebody else whether it's the
government or their partner their
husband their wife
for financial security that's very
dangerous so every individual should be
empowered and should have their own
financial stability that way
how do you ban how do you balance
building financial security but having
this fertility ticking time bomb it's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
how do you balance that
i don't know i'm in the middle of doing
it i'm balancing it it's really [ __ ] but
but that's life that's life and it's a
reality and it's a reality that i accept
it's a reality that i accept and so i
work harder than men i work harder to do
to so that i can have everything by 30.
this is what jordan peterson talks about
this is just the reality of it but the
important thing is that i'm that i'm far
away from 30
and so i'm very aware at this stage
and that is important it's just
awareness it's awareness of reality
which not a lot of women have so when
they get to 30 30 1 30 22 30 35 still
single and they're unhappy and they
don't understand why they can't find
someone and it's it's a whole can of
worms um but it's about having an honest
conversation and that's why it is harder
that's why women grow up faster than men
do women get periods at 12 years old and
have to deal with that in public like
how do you deal with that you go
swimming you know and
boys can still be children at that age
so women have it's harder to be a woman
in certain regards but it is what it is
it's okay and you know there are many
advantages at the same time men it's
also very hard to be a man at the same
time you know because there are a lot of
really difficulties
i've not found it hard at all no not
quite hard no i don't find it and i
think when i hear people complain and go
it's so hard for a like like a white
male they said i just don't experience
that i
i personally haven't uh i think every
opportunity is in front of me there's no
blocks in front of me for what i want to
do but i do see there's blocks for other
people you know depending on you know
the luck of the draw there are gender
blocks there are uh
ethnic
like
uh ethnicity blocks there are
geographical blocks i i just don't have
any in front of me but like i say i have
a daughter and i'm trying to be
empathetic to her trying to lead her in
in the right way and explain certain
things in the right way and some of it
you don't want to get it wrong some of
it's quite challenging
and uh it's very easy for somebody to
comment to just jump in there and just
like come out with a comment like they
know suddenly what the answer is these
are complicated issues you know these
are complicated things you're dealing
with when you're parenting and you want
to give your child the best opportunity
you want to empower them you don't want
to scare them uh but but you like right
now i'm like holy [ __ ] so i need to
think about this as well and this is
another thing so i'm gonna have to talk
to my mother and go on the phone and say
at what point do we deal with this you
know it's like you should it's just
about being too complicated yeah yeah
it's just about being truthful and you
know she can do anything she wants she
can be that boss ceo like i i love what
i do it comes from my heart it's not
really it's not about money it's about
freedom and i'm not going to stop but
unfortunately you know i do want to be a
mother as well and so not unfortunately
but like it's just unfortunate that i
have these two things that i want um and
so i will have to figure out a way to do
both and i'm just grateful that i'm
aware at this age because i'd be very
upset if i woke up you know i wish i was
aware even younger that you know that's
the truth i wish i was aware younger but
listen listen it's you know it's great
that you have that not everyone not
every girl does not everyone would have
the confidence to start a podcast and go
on and you know you know what it's like
i mean you take [ __ ] online and get all
the negative comments on you you choke
i'm all weirdos and everyone complaining
and you get the backseat listeners who
think they can do a better job and
really just because their lives are
miserable and their complete failures
they can't do anything but they want to
sit there and have a go at you
you've got the confidence to go out and
do that you're you're in the arena you
take the beatings and do it now i know
what it's like and it's tough not
everyone has that like not everyone has
that ability to do that and you will be
hugely successful you're going to make a
lot of money doing really well i mean
you're crushing it at 24. is it 24 i
don't know i'm guessing i'm not 24. if
you're younger i'm going to
be depressed but i'm saying you are
absolutely crushing it right but not
everybody has that confidence that
ability they don't have maybe the
educational background they don't have
the maybe you've got supporting parents
and they're impacted
yeah so or maybe you didn't have
supporting parents and it
like spurred you on
like there's like the world is made up
of different people and and not everyone
can go and do that i'm glad for you that
you can but not everyone's going to go
out and be able to do that be able to
get financially secure and independent
not rely on a man and and and and
but still you know put themselves in a
position when they want to go and have a
baby and and be able to support
themselves it doesn't work like it's
it's highly complex right yes [ __ ]
hard
all right i have to run into london now
i'm going to get an uber i'm too far
away um but i've had so much fun
chatting with you i'm so happy we did
this and we'll have to do it again in
person whether it's in london or miami
i don't know where we'll do it but peter
i want to thank you so much um i'll do
it anytime
you enjoy this i always talk to you and
uh but let's do it let's do it in person
next time and yeah comments come turn
the comments off because
honestly that [ __ ] idiots fed up a
little bit
no but thank you so much it's been so
good with you and let me know when
you're in miami or if you're in london
and we'll we'll meet up and we'll do
another one in person all right cool
anything you need just give me a shout
yeah perfect take care and i'm gonna see
i'm seeing you in miami yeah
yes i'll be there in april hopefully
they'll let me in um but yeah i'm about
to put my flights this week so yeah all
right cool i will see that my daughter
will be there you can meet her oh
that'll be great i'll i'll empower her
to go get her dreams while looking for
her no i'm joking she's too young okay
all right take care peace out bye
[Applause]
[Music]